with dignity and respect
committed to free speech in some sense
both be and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may have to take
each other hello and welcome to the
pledge it's a favorite with the older
generation can keep going for hours and
it gets our very own Nick Ferraris
screaming out loud no I'm talking about
a true British classic bingo
but now the masterminds behind the game
are getting down with the kids in an
attempt to entice a whole new generation
of players the big plan ditching their
traditional calls we know and love for a
whole lot of Lokanath phrases well never
ones to miss out an opportunity to join
in the fun we've come up with a plane go
special so ladies and gentlemen get your
dabbers at the ready and away we go
25 it's time to go live oh one famous
family number 38 not another brexit
debate 74 Carol's got more 87 Greg's on
the stairway to heaven
88 Nick's running late 49 it's time for
wine yes
somehow I'm not sure they'll catch on
coming up on the program families got
issues with Big Brother Carol wants
tougher sentences for those who attack
cops I'm saying anti-semitism isn't a
thing of the past and Nick is showing
sexism the red card in the workplace but
first it's Rachel the war is over the
people have spoken
again and what they've said is they
basically voted for us never to discuss
brexit on the pledge ever again I get
that I also want the healing to begin
but there's only 11 months to do the
deal every looming challenge or present
danger is won best not faced alone the
technological threats to sovereignty the
deadly virus sweeping the world global
climate change nuclear proliferation
terrorism there are reasons to be
cheerful the government can govern
confidence is bouncing back we can all
move on but can't tell a lie the brexit
50p
doesn't quite make up for what I feel my
children have lost the freedom to live
and work in 28 countries and common
cause and free trade with the market of
500 million on our doorstep war is over
but now for the hard part how easy is it
really going to be to win the peace okay
the fact that you guys were saying at
the loss of free movement isn't saying
to me one of the biggest things was art
that was argued about during the
referendum was free movement then argued
that movement will be just as free after
brexit essentially what we've had here
is for the past four years the country
as a whole has been arguing basically in
a car fighting over the steering wheel
over who gets to drive it where etc
right now Boris Johnson has wrestled
full control and now everybody is now
together in the back seat waiting to
find out where it goes we're gonna find
out whether or not Brett that's a good
idea or a bad idea that's where we're
heading I'm going on strike
I'm sorry this is the momentous moment
of the week which started with a
Holocaust Memorial Day on Monday even
you should admit we're leaving the
institution bear in mind people could be
watching this you've already left the EU
and amazingly still water in the taps
and the lights are on you took you
talked about the deadly virus I don't
quite see how you think being in the
European Union could come back the
strewn of Corona bar but there were oh
we've been to hang on we've been so
effective on the war against terrorism
tell that to the people of the cities
such as Paris Berlin nice and in London
that's really work well as to your point
of freedom the people of Switzerland
managed to get into mainland Europe what
are they forming very amazingly we will
still have freedom of movement don't
worry great European Union project faced
with the crisis of migration what utter
ly criminally incompetent it's over it's
bust
not for nothing does even the IMF say
that the British economy would outstrip
that of the eurozone I'm through I'm
joining his strike Carol you talk about
how are we gonna make the peace between
them we've had ok I'm celebrating but
I'm not triumph us however you talking
about winning the peace we are never
going to win the peace in this country
as long as remain as refuse to accept
what has happened let me finish my point
prep so this week
Boris tweeted that that was draw degree
would have been signed and he said we
are beginning a new chapter in our
history now let me let me you've all
heard of an actor called John Hannah
have you you know yeah the hold the
clocks are I for weddings he actually
tweeted this week just listen to this
and then pardon my language cuz I'm sure
someone would be blip guy he he said to
your brother
q you slimy fat self-serving arrogant
sadist that is what this is where we're
at
we shall media that this is the views of
remains can we just see under ad anuses
tweet which I did think was slightly
Petty and Lord adonus tweeted I am never
using or accepting this coin which says
peace prosperity and friendship with all
nations which seems fairly innocent to
me can we also while we're on the
subject of actors take a look at a clip
from Hugh Grant the star of Four
Weddings in a funeral I know that a few
weeks ago you were campaigning and I'm
just wondering how are you feeling now
that you know everything is kind of
settled are you encouraged in II know
it's a catastrophe so no no bright line
or horizon no country's finished I think
we can all agree Hugh Grant was
obviously joking he lives in loves and
works in this country anyway yes joking
I just want to say and explain perhaps
my opening line on this I think that so
I think hopefully everyone can agree
that the last experience we've just had
with a Labour leadership and some of the
division and divisive 'no stat calls in
the country has been a horrific
experience for many people in this
country I was surprised to learn that
actually only 26 percent of people I had
a row with somebody they care about over
the whole politics general election
situation whereas 48 percent of us
actually fought with somebody we care
about over brexit and and I thought I
think this debates an example of it so I
think actually what all of us I voted
remain I campaigned for a people's vote
I think personally we who lost that
debate should now be focusing on trying
to develop a positive Britain a vision
for a Liberals written beyond bridge you
can see them working with reps you can
see that it's not happening with many
remaining can I just suggest what I was
going to say so we remain as a loss the
debate should be working with brexit us
to try and develop a positive vision for
what we want our country to look like
going forward because the debates over
we've lost it by the way I can only
speak about it
complaining about whatever we did and
I'm not saying you're complaining and I
say I say where we're gonna lose
remainders and actually the polls
indicate that so now 50% and when you
take away they don't know as 54%
now that brexit and i think actually we
will lose support the more weeks we've
all accepted I think even if Emmy has
accepted it I had lunch with Nigel frosh
this week and we raised we raised it
colossal it was a three but no it wasn't
people like Hugh Grant and I don't
believe that was a joke at all I'm still
saying that you know by this this stage
and you know where we at we should be
going to hell in a handcart the opposite
is true okay last week 1,000
you've finance companies send them all
coming to open office great we have the
biggest jobs we again smash jobs wreck
rates 33 million people at home because
a lot of I'm not saying you would be I'm
talking about remainders in general you
say we are leaving but we will have less
well the issue of whether we leave or
not is going to be settled within 24
hours so that's not that's not really an
issue anymore the question is what is
going to happen this year Boris Johnson
has until the end of the year
to negotiate an international trade deal
in about a third of the time they took
him to negotiate a trade the other only
last 11 months at the end and at the end
of that it is either going to be
realistically staying out of the EU
rules with no say an extension or a No
Deal breakfast there are no good options
there
now you're gonna you're gonna tell me
that I should just get behind Britain
I'm sorry so you're not getting back
this is exactly what I'm saying to
people like you assembly except no but
you will not accept we're going to align
or we gonna diverge this is going to be
hugely important for every single
company and every single person in
Britain this is really important buy on
sale have the trade you by the end of
the year he's also things I am tired of
this idea that if you don't support the
direction that cut the country is
currently going you do not believe in
Britain and you do not love Britain we
are just as patriotic as the rest as the
rest is you the fact is if you if
somebody gets behind a car they can see
it's going off a cliff that person hates
that car and everyone in it anyone who
loves the people in that car should be
inside that car saying hey DRI
there's a quick you have zero faith in
this country and it shows you you cannot
believe we will make a success of this I
happen to think we will make a
successful more this happens more this
loses things even if you disagree with
what she's saying
we're losing support now 54% of backing
brexit the more this debate carries on
in this hostile adversarial way hold on
in the hostile adversarial way the more
remainders are gonna be painted as
bitter losers I think we need to divert
a divisor language in a way to
communicate with the cares of this world
way that in a way that makes her laugh
at me we are losing this debate Femi we
are losing it I've got I've got to just
correct you you're gonna use the polls
with 52 funnies in I do it to me now as
well we're losing the debate 52.7% vote
for parties that were committed to
having a second referendum I'm saying up
the polls and say that people I'm saying
all I'm saying is femi is it the more we
carry this on and you know you've got
the facts on your side I voted in that
direction the more we carry this on the
more we're gonna lose this debate what
we need to do is say is watch it devise
away a vision because you've presented
three options now if they're the only
three options we have to pick one of
them and then lobby for that one to
happen
agree agree and so that's what we should
be focusing on is what's the vision that
we want for the future for this country
to look like a very rare set I agree
with that yeah and the messaging needs
to reflect that I think rather than
reflect a tone that sounds as if we're
still upset about what happened in the
past that's my advice